[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
[موسيقى]
روسيا تضع صواريخ استراتيجيه في حاله
الجاهزيه تحذر من هجوم روسي واسع النطاق
نهايه الشهر
تحقيق للتايمز لا يستبعد تفجير خط نور
للغاز من قبل دوله غربيه ولا فروف يتهم
واشنطن بالتورط في ذلك
لاؤكد مره اخرى على عمق العلاقه
الوطيده بين بلدينا الشقيق وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه يؤكد عمق العلاقات مع بغداد
والرئيس العراقي يؤكد مواصله التنسيق في
قضايا اقليميه ودوليه
بعد رفع الاحتياطي الفيدرالي الامريكي
اسعار الفائده في البنوك
الاسعار الفائده البنوك العربيه تحدثها
برفع اسعار الفائده ايضا
اوكرانيه من هجوم روسي واسع النطاق في
الشمال والجنوب بنهايه الشهر الحالي
يقابلها تحركات روسيه عسكريه واسعه النطاق
اذ بدات منصات ذاتيه الحركه لصواريخ يارس
الاستراتيجيه مناوبات قتاليه في مسارات
معينه في منطقه الطاي بجنوب سيبيريا
ناطقون باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قال ان
منصات الصواريخ يارس تقوم بتنفيذ المهام
الخاصه بتغيير المواقع الميدانيه وتجهيزها
هندسيا
صواريخ ار اس 22
يصل مداها الى 12 الف كيلو متر
قادر على حمل اربعه رؤوس قتاليه
الخطا لا تتعدى 120 مترا قادره على تغيير
المواقع والتمويه
كذلك المناوره وتجاوز الدروع الصاروخيه
وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
كشف ايضا ان روسيا تحشد 500 الف جندي لشن
هجومي جديد يوم الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
في الذكرى الاولى لبدء الهجوم على
اوكرانيا واوضح ارزن ان الهجوم الروسيه
الذي وصفه بالكبير سيتركز في الشرق
والجنوب في السياق ذاتي اكدت المخابرات
الاوكرانيه عند الرئيس الروسي امر الجيش
بالسيطره على لوغانست ودوناسك بحلول مارس
واضافت المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان روسيا
تعيد نشر وحدات هجوميه ومعدات في الشرق
وقالت ان روسيا لن تستخدم اراضي بيلاروس
لشن هجوم واسع بسبب عدم وجود قوات كافيه
لذلك
[موسيقى]
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه اكد انه كلما قدم
الغرب والمزيد من الاسلحه بعيده المدى
لاوكرانيا كلما باتت هناك حاجه متزايده
لازاحتها بعيدا عن الاراضي الروسيه
وتعمل بروف الغربه بالسعي الى تكبيد روسيا
هزيمه استراتيجيه حتى لا تتمكن من التعافي
لعقول وتوقع ان تكون مولدوفا المشروع
الجديد المعادي لروسيا بعد اوكرانيا متهما
الغرب بجر جورجيا الى العداء مع روسيا
الابراج اضاف ان الغرب يريد تقويض علاقات
روسيا مع اسيا الوسطى مؤكدا ان روسيا
يمكنها تحقيق النجاح في اوكرانيا دون
مساعده دول سوفيتيه السابقه وفيما يختص
بعلاقه روسيا مع الصين اكداب ان العلاقه
مع بيكين اقوى من تحالف عسكري ولا حدود
لها
معي من موسكو مجددا لمزيد من المتابعه
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبد
الجواد اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد
الميداني اخر المواقف والتصريحات حتى
الساعه
مرحبا طالب نعم بالفعل يعني حديثه صباح
اليوم حول ان روايه الغرب بما يخص
جاهزيه موسكو للجلوس طاوله المفاوضات بانه
امر غير صحيح
وصف هذا الموضوع بالشيء الكاذب مضيفا بان
موسكو على جاهزيه لجلوس طاوله المفاوضات
اما مع الجانب الاوكراني او مع الجانب
الغربي لكن في حال وجود ملفات ونقاشات
حقيقيه للوصول الى حل للازمه الاوكرانيه
هذا على ما يبدو هو ابرز التصريحات
السياسيه لهذا اليوم بما يخص طبعا القضيه
الميدانيه طالبكم تحدثنا طبعا نلاحظ
الجديد بالموقف طبعا من شحن موسكو لتصعيد
ضرباتها العسكريه خلال هذه الفتره قبل
الوصول للرابع والعشرين من الشهر الجادي
موعد طبعا نور سنه على العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه موسكو طبعا
القراءه العسكريه والسياسيه فيها تتوجه
بانها لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي خلال المرحله
التي يقوم بها الغرب بدعم اوكرانيا اما
بدبابات من العيار الثقيل ويدور الحديث عن
مقاتلات وقد تصل الى صواريخ طبعا بعيده
المدى ما يسمح بالوصول الى مناطق حيويه
بالقرب من شبه جزيره القرم طالب لذلك طبعا
موسكو تسعى الان لابعاد الجيش الاوكراني
حسب الروايه العسكريه اكبر قدر ممكن على
المناطق الجنوبيه للابتعاد بهم على اقل
تقدير بضعه كيلومترات عن نهر النيبر التي
يقسم طبعا اوكرانيا الى عبد الجواد نعود
الى السؤال بس نعود الى السؤال المركزي
الان انه كل المعلومات الغربيه حتى
التصريحات الرسميه الاوكرانيه تتحدث
بصراحه عن حشد روسيا لنصف مليون جندي
موسكو تحضر لهجوم واسع النطاق حتى انهم
اعطوا تاريخ محدد في الرابع والعشرين واذا
عطفنا ذلك على يعني هذه التحركات
الاستراتيجيه لمنظومات الصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه يارس في جنوب
سيبيريا
الشيرات تلمسونها على الارض يعني من موسكو
وفي المدن الروسيه الاساسيه ان ثمه تحضير
لمثل هكذا هجوم ام لا يعني لا شيء يدعو
الى الاستغراب
طالب يعني رسميا لا يدور الحديث عن نصف
مليون جندي لكن قد يكون هذا الامر صحيحا
نوعا ما وقد تكون موسكو قد عدت العده بعدد
كبير من جنودها ومن صواريخها لكن اذا ما
تم النظر للعمليه العسكريه حسب القراءه في
البلاد فان ان نلاحظ بان موسكو تصعد من
عملياتها العسكريه ومن ضرباتها الصاروخيه
لا جديد بشكل ملحوظ كبير حول هذا الموضوع
الضربات الصاروخيه مستمره منذ مطلع هذا
العام الضربات
بالمدفعيه ايضا تلعب دور محرري محوري بشكل
كبير قوات فاجنر قوات رمضان قاديره القوات
الروسيه طبعا قوات دانيه تقوم بعمل محوري
كبير الان خاصه في هذه الفتره كما ذكرت
لذلك طبعا التقارير التي تتحدث عن ان
موسكو يعني تعد بشكل كبير لدخول في مرحله
اكبر مما يحدث هي تقارير حتى هذه اللحظه
غير مثبته محليا طبعا كما تحدث اليوم كما
تحدث بوتين يوم امس لا تبحث عن يعني ما
انصحها التعبير تكسير الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بشكل كبير يعني حتى هذه اللحظه كما يقول
العسكريون لا تقوم موسكو بقصف سكك الحديد
يعني سكك الحديد ستقوم بقطع ايصال المعدات
العسكريه الثقيله نحو النقاط العسكريه
الاوكرانيه لكنها ايضا في حال قصفت ستقوم
بقطع الاعمال التجاريه وامداد الطعام
والغذاء للمواطن الاوكراني وهذا طبعا ما
سيضع البلد وحكومه روسيا موضع سؤال امام
الشعب الروسي الذي ينظر الى هذه القضيه
والى الشعب الاوكراني من الجهه الانسانيه
بهذا الموضوع لذلك طبعا موسكو كما تحدثت
خلال الاسبوع الاخير لا تتمنى طبعا الوصول
لمرحله قد تستخدم بها صواريخ من العيار
الثقيل وقد تضطر طبعا لضرب سكك الحديد
يعني طرق الامداد التي تمد الغذاء قبل
السلاح للشعب الاردني من موسكو مراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد شكرا جزيلا لك
عبد الجواد على كل هذه المتابعه
افاده تقرير لصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه ان
التحليلات لخبراء لا تستبعد ان تكون دوله
غربيه هي من فجرت خط نور للغاز واضاف
المدير السابق لجهاز المخابرات الخارجيه
الالمانيه
ان الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وبولندا
واوكرانيا تستفيد من تفجير نورشرين
واشار تقرير تايمز ان تفجير روسيا لخط
الغاز يبدو مستبعده نظرا لانها بدات في
اصلاحه يذكر ان التفجيرات التي ضربت خطي
انابيب الغاز نرجس
ريم 2 في بحر البلطيق وقعت في سبتمبر
الماضي
اتهم وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الولايات
المتحده بتورطها بشكل مباشر في تفجيرات خط
انابيب الغاز نورستي وقال لابروف في
مقابله مع التلفزيون الروسي الرسمي انما
تمكنت موسكو من كشفه لا يقتصر على البرامج
العسكريه والبيولوجيه الامريكيه التي
تحاول واشنطن اثبات ان لا علاقه لهم بها
نقوم ايضا باعداد نوع من التقارير حول ما
حدث خلال العام الماضي وما تمكنا من كشفه
لا يقتصر على البرامج العسكريه
والبيولوجيه الامريكيه التي يحاولون اثبات
ان لا علاقه لهم بها بل هم يكذبون كما
يفعلون دائما الامر لا يتعلق فقط
بالمشاركه المباشره للولايات المتحده في
الانفجارات على خطوط انابيب نوت لقد
اعترفت وكيله وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
للشؤون السياسيه بانها مذنبه
اجرى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان زياره لبغداد التقى خلالها عدد
من المسؤولين العراقيين
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه اكد على عمق
العلاقات مع العراق التي شهدت زخما كبيرا
مؤخرا مشيرا الى دعم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لجهود الحكومه العراقيه لتعزيز
الاستقرار
كل جهود الحكومه العراقيه في سبيل تعزيز
الرخاء
والاستقرار في العراق
والسعي الى تحقيق
الاستدامه في النمو والازدهار للعراق وسوف
نعمل سويا لدعم هذا والتعاون في هذا
المجال بالذات من خلال تفعيل مجلس التنسيق
المشترك والذي يعمل على تفعيل مشاريع
عديده وفرص كثيره وهناك مجال واسع للتنسيق
والتعاون بين القطاعين الخاصين بالذات في
بلدينا لتعظيم الاستفاده من الفرص المتاحه
وزير الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين وخلال
مؤتمر الصحفي مع وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان اكد على وجود تنسيق
مشترك مع السعوديه في كل المجالات مشيرا
الى استمرار التعاون الامني والعمل على
تخفيف حاله التوتر في المنطقه العلاقات
الثنائيه بين طرفين تطورت
في مجالات مختلفه هناك تنسيق كامل
مع الجهات المعنيه والمسؤولين في المملكه
حول السياسه النفطيه
وحول تنسيق بين البلدين ضمن اطار اوبك
لدينا تعاون مستمر في المجال الامني
ومحاربه
عصابات المخدرات
نعمل معا لتخفيض حاله التواتر التوتر في
المنطقه
والسعوديه كدوله
ودوله قاعده
في الاطار الاسلامي
تلعب دورا مهما في هذا المجال
لمزيد من المتابعه لهذا الموضوع ينضم الي
من بغداد المحلل السياسي سرمدا البياتي
اهلا وسهلا بك كيف يجب النظر الى هذه
الزياره سواء من حيث التوقيت او المضامين
وهل يمكن منذ الان
تقييم نتائجها ام لا
نعم
بالنسبه الى التوقيت توقيت مهم جدا
بالوقت الحاضر لاسباب عديده طبعا اولها
ربما العراق لديه بعض المشاكل الاقتصاديه
الداخليه
هنالك بعض المشاكل ما تخص المخدرات وتخص
موضوع تنظيمات الارهابيه هذه
البلدين الجارين هم ثقل كبير بالوطن
العربي وبالشرق الاوسط لا بل بالعالم كله
السعوديه حقيقه
مبادراتها رائعه في هذا الوقت بالذات نحن
نعلم ان هنالك حكومه جديده لم يمضي عليها
اكثر من يمكن ثلاثه اشهر
التطور اللي بدات السعوديه وربما هنالك
تجاوب كبير من العراق في هذا الموضوع
التطور رائع الان ربما ساترك الكلام
المنمق حول
التنسيق وغيره وغيره لكن انا اقول لك فقط
هنالك سيارات عراقيه بسيارات بارقام
عراقيه تجوب السعوديه الان سيارات عراقيه
تذهب الى العمره هذه اول مره انا شاهدتها
في السبعينات الان العراقي ممكن ان يدخل
يؤدي العمره نعم يؤدي العمره بسياره
الشخصيه يستقل سيارته من اي محافظه يذهب
الى عرعر بعد ما تبرعت السعوديه ببناء
عرعر الحدودي وصار رفد منفذ انا زرته رائع
جدا ويعني بترتيب عالي جدا تدخل بسيارتك
بدون اي اشكالات وليس فقط ان تزور مكه
المكرمه والمدينه المنوره لا ممكن ان تذهب
الى جده او الرياض او اي منطقه اخرى يعني
يكفي انه اقول لك بانه هذا التطور اثار
ارتياحا كبيرا لدى المواطن العراقي الان
المواطن العراقي فرح جدا بهذا الموضوع نعم
الزياره هذه مهمه ربما هنالك
نتائج اخرى لهذه الزياره من المبكر القول
بها ربما تخص العلاقات حتى تخص العلاقات
السعوديه الايرانيه هنا اسالك هل ما زالت
مساعي بغداد مستمره في هذا المجال لاصلاح
ذات البين بين طهران والرياض واين وصلت
هذه المساعي اذا كان لديك معلومات وهل ما
زالت بغداد يعني وسيطا موثوقا من جميع
الاطراف في هذا المجال
ساقول لك انا ما سمعته قبل
اسبوعين وجهت لي سؤال مهم احذر قنوات
قالوا لي هل هنالك على اعتبار اثيرت شائعه
عن انقطاع المباحثات السعوديه الايرانيه
التي تجري على ارض العراقيه
لي هذا السؤال انا ما كنت اعرف الجواب
لانه حقيقه ما الامور مختلطه
سالت اهم المسؤولين عن هذا الملف قلت له
هل هنالك انقطاع في هذا الموضوع انتبه
ماذا قال لي قال لي ستشهد خلال اسبوعين
لقاءات على مستوى عالي جدا بين السعوديه
وايران
ويبدو انه هذه
زياره اليوم السيد فيصل بالاضافه الى كل
الامور اللي تكلمنا بها على المحاربه
المخدرات على العمل الاقتصادي المشترك على
اوبك ربما ستعيد هذه المباحثات المباحثات
لم تنقطع لا بل دفعها ربما نشهد افتتاح
سفارات في هذا الموضوع ربما نشهد الكثير
من الامور نعم ربما نشهد الكثير من الامور
وهذا كله من اجل صالح العراق والسعوديه
ومن اجل هذين الشعبين هم كتله واحده حقيقه
يعني لذلك نتمنى ان نبقى مجلس التنسيق
المشترك ان يفعل ان نسمح للاستثمارات
السعوديه السعوديه طرحت في زمن الكاظمي ان
تستثمر مليون مليون دونم في الاراضي
العراقيه من اجل نقل يعني انا اقول لك
هنالك شركات المراعي يعني طرحوا قالوا
ننقلها من جميع انحاء العالم الى ارض
العراقيه هذا شيء رائع جدا نعمل خيرا نعمل
خيرا
ساكتفي بهذا القدر بهذا الكلام الايجابي
المتفائل من بغداد المحلل السياسي سرمد
البياتي شكرا على هذه المشاركه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره في ايضا
على خلفيه الاحتجاجات السلطات الايرانيه
تعتقل اكثر من 180 كرديا بينهم نساء
واطفال
اهلا بكم من جديد اعتقلت السلطات
الايرانيه ما لا يقل عن 185 شخصا خلال شهر
يناير الماضي في بلوشستان ايران وفق
تقارير اعلاميه حقوقيه وبحسب موقع حلوش من
المحتمل ان يكون المعتقلون حديثا في مدينه
زهدان اعلم من 185 شخصا وذلك بسبب الاجواء
الامنيه الشديده وحملات الاعتقال واسعه
النطاق اضافه الى انقطاع الانترنت
[موسيقى]
النشطه المدنيه الايرانيه السجينه نرجس
محمد هي واحده من ثلاثه ناشطين حقوقيين
تسعى مؤسسه اوليف بالما السويديه لتقديم
جائزه لها
وقد قالت محمد في رساله كتبتها وقراها
زوجها ان جهاز القمع في الحكومه الذي
وصفته بالاستبدادي اغلق الطريقه على مدى
اربعه واربعين عاما امام اي حراك سياسي
واجتماعي وذلك من خلال القمع الشديد
المعارضين والمحتاجين واحتواء صناديق
الاقتراع واصوات الناس
وانتقدت محمد ايضا سياسات النظام الايراني
الاقليميه والدوريه مضيحه ان النظام
الحالي في ايران لم يهدد تحقيق
الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان فحسب بل ايضا
السلام والامن والتنميه في البلاد
والمنطقه مشدده على انها تدافع عن حقوق
الانسان وتسعى الى السلام
لا يتوقف النظام عن ملاحقه واستهداف الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني المعارض
غارات عده شنتها طهران ضد مقر الحزب
ومؤسساته
الغارات الايرانيه الاخيره استهدفت اهم
مقار الحزب في كردستان المعروف بالقلعه
ودمرته جزئيا العربيه وضمن تغطيتها
الحصريه تفقدت المكان ونقلت صورا تظهر حجم
الدمار في المقر الذي بات مهجورا
[موسيقى]
نشق طريقنا وسط هذا الدمار في هذا المبنى
الذي عرف بالقلعه قبل اشهر فقط كان حصنا
ومقرا لمعارضين ايرانيين لكنه لم يكن
منيعا ضد ضربات النظام الايراني
[موسيقى]
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
اقدم واهم الاحزاب الايرانيه المعارضه من
هنا من قلعته في قويسنجق في كردستان
العراق كان يدير عمليات السياسيه وما
تتبعه من منظمات طلابيه شبابيه ونسائيه
لكن هذا المقر كثيرا ما كان يتعرض لضربات
ايران ازدادت الضربات مع المظاهرات
الايرانيه الاخيره واتهام ايران لهذه
الاحزاب باداره وقياده المظاهرات التي
انطلقت في ايران منذ اشهر ولم تهدا الى
غايه الان اذا هذه بقايا احد الصواريخ
الايرانيه يقول السيد اماجو هو قيادي في
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
المعارض بان هذه القطع الصغيره هي قطع
معدنيه الهدف منها هو ايقاع اكبر قدر من
القتلى في هذه الضربات الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
تم قصف هذا المكان ومخيم اللاجئين
والمدارس بصواريخ النظام كانت المدرسه
تستضيف 220 طالبا في غضون ذلك قصف النظام
ايضا حزب الحريه الكردستاني قصف النظام
الاحزاب الثلاثه في نفس الوقت قصفت هذه
القلعه بسبعه وثلاثين صاروخا بالاضافه الى
طائرات مسيره انتحاريه
منذ استقر الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني في العراق في تسعينات القرن
الماضي كانت مقره اهدافا دائمه لضربات
طهران لكنها مع اضطرابات داخل الايراني
باتت اشد واقسى نظام الايراني يخاف من هذا
الثوره ويخاف من سياسي الشعب الكردي في
ايران
[موسيقى]
اعين النظام الايراني ليست فقط على سياسي
وعسكريين الديمقراطي الكردستاني والاحزاب
الاخرى المعارضه وانما كذلك على الجيل
الجديد الذي ينشا بعيدا عن دعايه المرشد
والنظام الايراني
هذه كانت مدرسه مخصصه لاطفال اللاجئين
الاكراد هنا في قوي ولكنها تعرضت لقصف
ايراني وهجرت منذ ذلك الحين
[موسيقى]
استهداف مدرسه للاجئين ومواقع السكنيه
كويسنجق او كويا وهذا الاسم الكردي
للمنطقه جعل السؤال عن الغايه الايرانيه
مشروعا اذكر الاحوال على سبيل لهم الى
البقاء في حاله استنفار دائمه
التي ترونها هنا تحرس مخيمات اللاجئين
والعائلات الموجوده قواعدنا العسكريه
الرئيسيه قريبه من الحدود وهذا المكان
موقع مدني لتقليل مخاطر الهجمات بالصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره وزعنا قوه
للدفاع عن المخيمات
يجزم المعارضون الايرانيون انجيلا يتهجى
الحريه والديمقراطيه اكثر ازعاجا للمرشد
ونظامه الذي يسعى لخنق اصواتهم ومطالبهم
مطالب تردد صداها في مظاهرات ايران
الاخيره
وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال مسؤول
العلاقات العامه في الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني المعارض قال ان
النظام الايرانيه تعامل مع المتظاهرين
ورجال الدين والاقليات باقصى الاساليب
وسياسه الضغط والتعذيب والاعتقاد احنا
نشوف يعني حالات
واجهت النظام الايراني مع متظاهرين يعني
هما يقومون باسوى حاله تعامل مع متظاهرين
بنات
شباب
الجامعات حتى الشخصيات الدينيه
تشوف عسى في زاهدان في كردستان في منطقه
الاحواز
وباقي مناطق الايران مواطنين يواجهون
بسياسه
اعتقال والتعذيب نشيطين المجتمع المدني
دعوه الامن القوميه الاسرائيلي اليمني
لتمار بن جفير الى اجتماع عاجل لمجلس
الوزراء المصغر وذلك لبحث سبل الرد على
اطلاق صاروخ من غزه
وربط بن جرير بين اطلاق الصاروخ
والتحركه لاغلاق مخبزين يديرهما اشرف
فلسطينيون في سجنين اسرائيليين واضاف ان
اطلاق الصاروخ من غزه لن يضعف من عزيمه
الحكومه حسب تعبير
من القدس مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي زياد
اهلا وسهلا بك هل سيستجيب مجلس الوزراء
المصغر لدعوه ينعقد لبحث اطلاق الصاروخ من
غزه ام لا لا حديث عن اجتماع للرد على
اطلاق هذا الصاروخ زياد
لا اساسا انقضى هذا الموضوع هذا الموضوع
سبق
التبادل القصف الليلي بين الجانبين
وبالتالي كان هناك جوله قصيره ومحدوده من
تبادل القصف اطلقت في شنت فيها اسرائيل
غارات قالت انها طالت مخازن تصنيع سلاح
وتخزين في موقعين وسط قطاع غزه وجنوب
مدينه غزه فيما قالت حماس والفصائل
الفلسطينيه بانها اطلقت اثني عشر صاروخا
وقذيفه تجاه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
الحدوديه واستخدم ايضا كما في المره
الماضيه قبل اسبوع فقط استخدم ايضا
استخدمت صواريخ مضاده للطائرات اقرت
اسرائيل ايضا هذه المره بهذا الموضوع لكن
كما سبق واشرنا عندما يتصل الامر بقطاع
غزه عاده يكون هناك تحركات سريعه لان
التاثير الاقليمي يمكن ان يؤتي ثم
وبالتالي سيكون اليوم وفد من الجهاد
الاسلامي في القاهره مع المخابرات المصريه
وتم دعوه حماس ايضا زياد شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه المتابعه انا مضطر لانتقل
مباشره الى موسكو وهذه الكلمه للرئيس
الروسي
يمكن ادراك قوه مقاتلين وضباطنا
بحبهم للوطن
وقناعتهم القويه بان الحق معنا
من اجل الحقيقه
هذا في دمي شعبنا والحقيقه
دمرت النازيه
صارت رمزا
لقوته شعبنا
وهذه المدينه
والقرى المحيطه به بنيت من الصفر اذ لم
يبقى هنا اي مبنى سليم ولا شجره
ان تفعني حماه
تدهش حتى الان وتثير المشاعر الاحترام
والامتنان
وواجبنا المعنوي امام الجنود المنتصرين ان
نحافظ على ذكرى
وان نسلمها
للاجيال القادمه ولا نسمح لاحد بتحريف
ذكرى الانتصار على النازيه وتحرير العالم
من هذا الشر المطلق للاسف نرى ان
ايديولوجيه النازيه اليوم
عادت لتشكل خطرا مباشرا على امن بلدنا
فنحن مضطرون من جديد ان نجابها
عدوانا الغرب
واعاده يهددوننا بدبابات الالمانيه
ذات الصلبان على
اجنابها
ويريدون الان ان يقاتلون في اراضي
اوكرانيا بايدي
خلفاء هتلر من جماعه اتباعي
النخب الغربيه المعاديه لنا ولدينا اصدقاء
كثيرون في كل العالم بما في ذلك في القاره
الامريكيه وفي افريقيا وفي اوروبا ولكن من
يجرون الدول الاوروبيه بما فيها المانيا
الى حرب جديده مع روسيا
ويعلن عن هذا بلا مسؤوليه على انها حقيقه
واقعه من يعولون
الانتصار على روسيا في ساحه المعارك
على الاغلب لا يدركون ان الحرب مع روسيا
ستكون مختلفه
جدا لهم نحن لا نرسل الدباباتنا الى
حدودهم ولكن لدينا ما نرد به
ولن ينتهي الامر باللجوء الى المدرعات يجب
ان يدرك هذا الجميع ومن يهددوننا
ربما لم يفهموا حقيقه واضحه شعبنا كله
كلنا
تشربنا
تقاليد شعبنا
جيل المنتصرين الذين
بنوا بلدنا بدمهم وعرفهم
وسلموها لنا
ان الثبات حمايه السلندرات
عباره عن مثال نحتدي به وجنودنا وضباطنا
يحتذون بهم
طوال الاجيال والقيم والتقاليد هذا ما
يميز روسيا ويجعلنا اقوياء
في هذا القدر من كلمه الرئيس الروسي في
الذكرى الثمانين لمعركه ستالينغراد بالطبع
قال خصوصا يعني ارسال دبابات ليوبارد
لدينا ما نرد به على ارسال هذه الدبابات
ومن يهددون لا يفهموا طبيعه الشعب الروسي
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكيه ان التزام
الولايات المتحده بالدفاع عن الفلبين صارم
مشددا على ان واشنطن لا تسعى لاقامه قواعد
دائمه في الفلبين بل الى معالجه الانشطه
المزعزعه للاستقرار اما بخصوص تهديد كوريا
الشماليه فقد افاد اوستن ان هدف امريكا
الاول هو زياده الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه مؤكدا العمل مع الحلفاء بشكل دائم
للتاكد من وجود قوات ذات مصداقيه في
المنطقه
الخارجيه الصينيه اعتبرت من جهتها ان فتح
الفلبين اراضيها امام التواجد العسكري
الامريكي يضر بالاستقرار الاقليمي ويزيد
من التوترات
لطالما اعتقدت الصين باستمرار ان التعاون
الدفاعي والامني بين الدول يجب ان يفضي
الى السلام والاستقرار الاقليميين ويجب
الا يستهدف او يضر مصالح اطراف اخرى تواصل
الولايات المتحده تعزيز انتشار جيشها في
المنطقه الامر الذي يزيد التوتر ويضر
بالسلام والاستقرار الاقليميين يجب على
دول المنطقه توخل اليقظه وتجنب التعرض
للمخاطر من قبل الولايات المتحده
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي من
القاهره الان الدكتور احمد قنديل وهو
الباحث في الشؤون الاسيويه دكتور احمد
اهلا وسهلا بك الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه ما الذي يستبطنه برايك هذا التحرك
الامريكي باتجاه الفلبين الان عبر تدشين
قاعده عسكريه جديده والى اي مدى هذا موجه
مباشره الى الصين لا اكثر ولا اقل
مساء الخير على حضرتك اعتقد ان الاتفاق
الذي توصلت اليه الولايات المتحده مع
الفلبين انتصار دبلوماسي وعسكري كبير
لواشنطن في ظل المنافسه المتزايده مع
الصين واعتبار الامريكيين الصين هي
المنافس والتحدي الاستراتيجي الاهم في
التفكير الاستراتي الاستراتيجي الامريكي
في العالم
الفلبين كانت ممتنعه عن تطوير علاقاتها
الدفاعيه والامنيه مع الولايات المتحده
خلال فتره الرئيس الفلبين السابق
اللي جاء محل بدلا منه في يونيو الماضي
رئيسا جديدا هو فريند ماركوس الابن وهو
يعني كان في خلال الفتره الماضيه يبدو
يوازن بين
تعزيز العلاقات مع الصين اللي شهدت قفزات
كبيره خلال الثماني سنوات الاخيره سواء من
حيث تبادل التجاري او الاستثماري او
مشروعات متعدده وبين الحريف الامني
والاستراتيجي والولايات المتحده يبدو ان
الرئيس الفلبيني استقر على
الجانب الامريكي
واعطى الامريكيين حقيقه مزايا استراتيجيه
كبيره ليست بناء قواعد عسكريه جديده ولكن
السماح لهم باستخدام اربع مواقع جديده
بالاضافه الى خمس مواقع كان قد تم الاتفاق
حول
استخدامها كمخازن الاسلحه او يعني نوع من
انواع الدعم اللوجستيكي للقوات الامريكيه
في منطقه بحر الصين الجنوبي هذا التطور
بدون شك سوف يخلق الصينيين بشكل كبير لان
الفلبين تعتبر البوابه الجنوبيه الشرقيه ل
ااا
السؤال جيد هنا السؤال طيب واشنطن صنفت
الصين بانها العدو الاستر الاول وكل هذه
التحركات التي نراها تحديدا الان في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه هل هذا يدفعنا الى
التساؤل المشروع انه كلما تقدم الوقت كلما
اقتربنا اكثر فاكثر الى المواجهه المباشره
سواء بالواسطه او بغير الواسطه بين
الولايات المتحده والصين تعرف في ناس حطوا
تواريخ يعني قالوا لك بالعشرين 24 او
بالعشرين 25
نعم هذا السؤال مهم للغايه وانقسم
المراقبون بشان الاجابه عليه هناك وجهه
نظر ترى ان تعزيز التواجد العسكري
الامريكي في المنطقه سوف يرضع الصين وسوف
يمنعها من محاوله نشر افكارها وقيامها
الاستبداديه في المنطقه وسوف يمنحها ايضا
من محاوله تغيير الامر الواقع في بحر
الصين الجنوبي وبحر الصين الشرقي اللي فيه
منازعات كثيره بين الصين ودول هذه هاتين
المنطقتين في في ما يتعلق على السياده حول
الجزر وما الى ذلك هذه وجهه نظر وهذه يعني
رؤيه تعزز او ترغب في زياده تواجد العسكري
الامريكي في المنطقه زياده الاهتمام
الامريكي بحريه الملاحه ولكن هناك وجهه
نظر اخرى ترى ان ذلك سوف يدفع المنطقه الى
حرب بارده جديده وسوف يعني يزيد من مشاعر
عدم الثقه لدى
مستمره وفي ايضا
استراليا تلغي صور ملوك بريطانيا بما فيهم
الملك تشارلز الثالث من الاوراق النقديه
من فئه الخمسه دولارات
اهلا بكم من جديد الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز امرا ملكيا باعفاء الدكتور فهد
المبارك من منصبه كمحافظ للبنك المركزي مع
تعيينه مستشارا بالديوان الملكي بمرتبه
وزير
كما اصدر الملك سلمان امرا ملكيا بتعيين
ايمن السياري محافظا للبنك المركزي بمرتبه
وزير
في خطوه متوقعه رفع الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
الامريكي اسعار الفائده بخمسه وعشرين نقطه
اساس الى نطاق بين
4.5.75
واوضح رئيس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي الامريكي
ان الاقتصاد الامريكي يحقق نموا متواضعا
ومكاسب قويه في الوظائف مشيرا لانه يرى
طريقا للعوده الى مستوى التضخم المستهدف
عند اثنين بالمئه دون حدوث انكماش اقتصادي
كبير او زياده في معدلات البطاله
كما اضاف باول انه قد لا يكون امام البنك
الا بضع زيادات اخرى في اسعار الفائده
لخفض التضخم الى المستوى المستهدف
وعقد قرار الفيدراليه الامريكي لحقت
البنوك المركزيه في السعوديه والامارات
والبحرين وسلطنه عمان بخطوه الفيدراليه
الامريكيه برفع اسعار الفائده فيما ابقي
المركزي القطري على سعر الفائده دون تغيير
[موسيقى]
اذهب الى بيروت لمزيد من المتابعين انضم
الي من هناك استاذ التمويل الدولي في
الجامعه الامريكيه في بيروت الدكتور جهاد
الحكيم دكتور جهاد اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه
وباختصار هل كان متوقع بالنسبه اليك رفع
الفيدرالي الامريكي للفائده ب 25 نقطه
اساس ام لا كان مستغربا واستطراضا لماذا
حدث معظم دول الخليج او البنوك المركزيه
في دول الخليج حذو الفيدرالي الامريكي
ورفعت الفائده باستثناء قطر ما علاقه هذا
بذات
شكرا للاستضافه نعم هذا كان متوقعا لكن
كانت الاسواق الماليه في العالم تتوقع ان
يكون حديث البلد اكثر تشددا لذلك كون انه
كان
بصريح العباره تكلم عن الديسي انفليشن انه
يمكن انه تجاوزنا مرحله التضخم وانه لن
تبقى الفوائد مرتفعه لفتره طويله فهم
يتوقعون فقط ان يزيد فقط بعد ربع بالمئه
خلال هذه السنه ويمكن في اخر هذه السنه
يقوم بتخفيض هذه الفوائد فلذلك راينا ان
اسعار الاسهم ارتفعت لماذا الدول الخليجيه
رفعت سعر الفائده لانها هي تثبت بشكل او
باخر عملتها تجاه الدولار الامريكي لذلك
عندما تزيد كلفه
الاستدانه او كلفه راس المال في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على الدولار الامريكي
دول التي تثبت عملتها على الدولار بشكل او
باخر هي مضطره بان ترفع الفوائد بدورها
طيب دكتور حكيم معلب بطريقه مبسطه الانسان
المواطن العربي سواء في دول الخليج او
بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
يعني شو حيتغير علي ما الذي يعني سينتجه
ذلك
انعكاس ذلك على حياته فقط لنفهم انه اذا
ارتفعت سعر الفائده بالفدراري الامريكي
رفعه 25 نقطه اساسات شو بيتغير عليه
كل فتره الاستدانه عندما تزيد كل فتره راس
كلفه راس المال كل فتره التمويل في حال
اراد ان ياخذ قرضا جديدا ام في حال ان
القرض الذي هو قد استحوذ عليه ويجب ان
يدفع الدفع الشهريه فستزيد الدفعه الشهريه
في حال كان الفائده هي متحركه طيب
معظم دول الخليج قلنا يعني رفعت حدث
الفيدرالي الامريكي باستثناء قطر لم تغير
شيء في الفائده لماذا يعني الامارات سلطنه
عمان البحرين السعوديه حدث حدو الفدره
الامريكي في حين قطر برايك ضلت ولم تغير
اسعار الفائده
ربع بالمئه ليس بشكل كبير وايضا يتوقع
المحللين والخبراء الاقتصاديين انه سيكون
هنالك يمكن تخفيض لكلفه راس المال او لسعر
الفائده في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فاعتبرت قطر ان من اجل تنشيط اقتصاديها
ارادت ان تبقي اسعار الفائده منخفضه لانه
عاده نرفع سعر الفائده من اجل مكافحه
التضخم او من نبقي الفائده او نخفضها في
حال نريد ان ننعش الاقتصاد ربع بالمئه ليس
النسبه الكبيره فيمكن ان يرتئي حكام
المصارف المركزيه في بعض الدول ان تاخذ
بعين الاعتبار الحاله الاقتصاديه الموجوده
في في بلد معين لكن اذا كان الفرق شاسع
وتريد ان تبقي
السعر العمله مثبت تجاه عمله اخرى فمضطر
ان تحزوا حزوها والا سيكون هنالك رهوب
هروب لرؤوس الاموال من البلد الذي لم يرفع
الفائده البلد الذي فيه فائده اعلى وفيه
مخاطر عاده اقل استاذ التمويل الدولي في
الجامعه الامريكيه في بيروت الدكتور جهاد
الحكيم شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
شكرا لك زياده اخيرا اعلن المصرف المركزي
البريطاني ان صور ملوك بريطانيا ستختفي من
الاوراق النقديه في استراليا من فئه الخمس
دولارات
[موسيقى]
نشط الخامسه المفصله من العربيه انتهت
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]